. There are growing concerns among anyone
who's seen recent video of the president
that Donald Trump is having a major
problem communicating coherently.
I know that that's been a problem for years, but
that it's happening even more right now. Trump has
been doing rallies at a very high rate, sometimes
three rallies in different states in one day.
And the things coming out of his mouth have
gone from factually wrong to straight up
unintelligible. One such rally over the weekend
was in Lumberton, North Carolina, on Saturday,
an important state where Joe Biden has a very
small lead right now in the latest polls could
go either way. And here is Donald Trump
talking about, I guess the wall with Mexico
is the topic. But I am issuing a challenge to
you. What on earth is Donald Trump saying here?
And Mexico is praying for the world. I'd like
to have you say. Once it was complete, once I
knew the wall and we can't talk about the wall
anymore. Then they said. Oh, listen. But Mexico's
not paying for it. No, they are paying for it now.
They told me they don't know what the hell to do.
Just one of those. I said, I don't want to do.
Mexico is going to pay for the wall when it's
built. But because it's already, Bill, you don't
have to say it anymore. But they did pay for it.
But, of course, in reality, it's not been built.
What is he talking about? I checked. Please
let me know. What exactly is Donald
Trump saying here? Another strange
moment at a rally Saturday in Ohio. Trump
saying Joe Biden draws flies, which. It's
it's weird because No. One. The most notable
moment from the vice presidential debate was
when a fly literally landed on Mike Pence.
Not not figuratively. There's some, you know,
religious metaphors about flies landing on you
that don't mean much to me. A fly literally
landed on Mike Pence. And the number two, as
you'll see here, Trump actually had a fly on
him during this rally. You can't write this stuff.
You don't want sleepy Joe to be your president.
You know, he draws flies.
He's not drawing anybody.
All of this stuff, they're tired of such negative.
Hey, by the way, I had it. Here I am. I mean.
It used to be that if you had it, you
were immune for life, for it, for life.
How strange a time are we living it? Not
only that, Trump is saying Biden draws flies,
but that during his weekend rallies, he also had
a fly on him. It's inconceivable. It almost is
beyond. If this was a screenplay, you would say
it's not. It's too it's too out there. It's too
cliche. We can't do it. It's not believable.
Remember last week that Donald Trump cut a
rally short because it was too cold for
him this time, complaining that it's too
hot and he's going to have to cut it short again.
Is that sun hot or going to be a lobster? Do you
mind if I get this one at about one third because
I'm going to be one hell of a sunburned person.
Does anybody have some sun protection
for your president, please?
This is beautiful. Oh, man.
I said to my kids, stay out of this. Always
use sunblock. Hey, I always use sunblock and
here I am. That's really brilliant.
And then the president claiming that
Joe Biden is the candidate of needless
death, which, again, it's just projection.
Biden is a candidate of
endless war and needless death.
Of course, needless death. You know, Donald,
needless death, Trump might as well be the guy's
middle name. He, due to his completely failed
Corona virus, responds numerous respected studies,
pointing out many deaths that were not necessary.
Needless death. In this next clip, Donald Trump
seems to think that this is just weird. Trump
seems to think the Paris climate accords are
in some way specific to Paris. It's really
weird. Like he says, look at how Paris is doing.
And we're not in the Paris accord. We
don't feel like spending trillions of
dollars and destroying our business.
How's it doing for Paris? Not so well.
Very strange. Donald Trump might be shocked to
know that the Camp David Accords were not actually
about circumstances at Camp David. And then as
a final touch at the rally in who knows where
this one even was at this point, I can't keep
it straight. Was this Florida, North Carolina,
Ohio? I don't know. A guy threw out the event
repeatedly flashing a white power sign with his
right hand right behind. Trump was noticed right
away by people watching the rally. So certainly
anybody watching this stuff has to understand
the behavior is becoming increasingly erratic.
Trump continuing to launch brutal
assaults on the English language,
but also on common decency and also on democracy.
And now the latest is the White House seems to
have formally given up on controlling the
pandemic. I want to talk about that next.